hello everyone and welcome back to the
Women's World Chess Championship match
it's a game 12th and Alexandra coriaci
cannot add the Challenger is in a very
difficult position she needs to win on
demands to keep the championship going
and to take the championship into rapid
tiebreaks now if you've been following
the championship so far you know that
the jus engine took the lead then Maria
llena retaliated then garage cannot -
deleted then jus engine equalized and
then in game 10 Joe and June again took
the lead game 11 ended in a draw and now
it's the final game of the match unless
Gretchen is able to score a win so as a
very similar situation like Kasparov
versus carp of their famous match in
1987 in Seville and Kasparov also needed
to win under man so let's see what
happens here good actually not opens
with d4 that will be 5 by Joe in June
and now Knight to c3 so similar to
Kasparov garage Cano goes for an offbeat
opening and well I put Joe engine into a
deep thing and here already and move to
June June took 20 minutes to decide on
the next move and she replied with
Knight to f6 and ok this is definitely
the best reply at the last Knight to c3
idea which blocks the pawn usually one
of course to bring your pawn to c4 only
then develop the knight but here you
need a win and you can just play
anything you know that Julian June is
very well prepared as you've seen so far
in the match and immediately Bishop the
f4 by garage kena okay with east 6 and
now Knight the b5 already threatening
the capture on c7 with check so it seems
like you know it's only moved for you're
threatening a knight captures on c7 with
check pretty much seems like playing for
tricks but a lot of very strong
grandmasters have have tried this idea
would white like Alexander Botanica also
Aikido Alex saying call one of the
candidates of the 2020 candidates
tournament and the Duelist continues so
here at night to a6 you need to defend
the c7 pawn and our e3
continuing development with Bishop to b4
check forcing c3 well not forcing but
provoking provoking c3 and now the the
night does not have the c3 square to
retreat
so mr. back to e7 and now a four so you
can retreat the knight to a3 without
blocking you're a pawn
so basically what Gardner is trying to
do is keep as many pieces on the board
for as long as possible and try and
create as many complications as possible
so here we have castles and now like I
mentioned I have a lot of stuff Kovalev
won a very nice game with h3 here we
have Bishop to d3 Bogoria China and now
C 6 C 6 pushing the knight back
Knight to a 3 and now C 5 now you either
waste a move with knife to be 5 to get
the knife to a more active square which
was played in Alexander botany versus
admit refigure of into 2017 where botany
scored a very nice victory but here we
have Knight to f3 Bogoria phenom and it
is as a move 10 that we have a
completely new game so let's see what
happens we're Knights to e4 now
preparing a5 denied is excellently
placed on e4 with h3 and f5 it does
weaken the e6 pawn a bit but doesn't
seem like White has any ways of
exploiting that so nice back to be 5 and
now at sea for pushing the bishop
further back Bishop captures on e4 not
interested in in retreating so captures
captures and now Knight to e5 so ok the
knight is now on an excellent square
with nice to be 8 by JunJun preparing
now to kick away the night with a 6 and
here go really not castles we have a 6
pushing the knight back night back to a3
and now Knight to d7 developing and
maybe maybe even considering a trade
here on e5 we have knight back to see -
and now Quinta e8 not allowing this
Queen to go to a h5 but also putting
pressure on the a4 pawn if if the rook
ever moves so f3 busting open the center
we have Knight captures on e5 Bishop
captures on e5 and now Bishop to d7
just continuing development the rook
cannot come into the game and now Knight
the e1 so so far nothing really
happening it's hard to
hard to even imagine that white is
playing for a win here but in a
situation if you've ever seen the
interview with Kasparov about that game
he said that well you should just check
out that interview about that last game
how to play for a win when you simply
must win the game so Queen to h5 now if
if captures then you can trade Queens on
the spot so King H to improving the
position of the King and now e captures
an f3
we have Knight captures and now this is
a pretty bad better with all these pawns
and light squares but if you can get it
for example to g6 and maybe put it to e4
or or maybe even d3 in some lines could
be it could be very dangerous so Bishop
- I ate and now Quinta II won by garage
King on preparing efore which will
either allow he captures on d5 which
will weak in black center or if black
captures then you will weaken the c4
pawn and you will be able to make some
progress
so Queen to g6 preventing that and then
now Bishop back to f4 clearing the e5
square for the knight
we have Quinta efore now not allowing 95
to come with an attack on the Queen and
now a5 paralyzing the Queen side now the
rook can also move since you don't have
to worry about for example - of captures
an a4 with h6 by black and now Knight
the d2 kicking the Queen back so just a
92 the Queen has to move now preparing
e4 Queen back to h7 and now efore and
now here you could either wait wait for
D captures on e5 which isn't all that
great for black since you you open up
lines for white so D captures an e4 was
played and then now before recapturing
Bishop to e5 so what do you do here well
there are a few things to consider you
are up upon for the moment but this is a
weak point and this is a weak point so
first look the c8 defending the the c4
pawn there's no there's no good way to
defend the e4 pawn we have root
characters on f8 Bishop characters on f8
and now Queen - E - putting another
attacker
words the the c4 pawn and now you could
play Bishop e5 yes this defense it
however the knight characters on e4 and
you've regained the material balance and
the black has a pawn bishop so not
really something you're interested in
what's best for black is actually to go
Bishop to e7 but this is not an easy
decision to make and after lights the
united captures any for now you bring
the bishop to c6 and after the knight
moves now we bring it to d5 so now from
here bishop defense c4 bishop defense
east six bishop defends b7 and also bush
of attacks g2 so this is one good bishop
so that's how you should how you should
approach it you should put it here and
after d4 pawn is going you you gain
access to this diagonal but garage
chicken a story I do in June finds an a
different plan and active one she plays
III point being that if Queen captures
then you defend with Queen to d3 or a
queen trade you could get a very nice
pass pawn on d3 and with the bishop pair
should be very nice however after this
III move buddy H gonna plays Knight
captures on c4 and the now Bishop to b5
okay attacking the knight of sort of
pinning the attacked piece and now b3
defending with Queen to f4 and now
adding another defender to the e3 pawn
so what do you play here feel free to
pause the video and try to find how to
continue this game with white while I
give you a couple of seconds so for
those of you who are able to do it there
is only one move that gives white an
advantage and that is rook to f1 rook to
f1 with the threat of rook to f4 kicking
away the black Queen and then just
gobbling up the e3 pawn if you trade
trading doesn't do anything for you
because after captures there's also
captures and then well a lot of things
are hanging here it would just be
winning for black pretty much so like I
said rook the f1 the threat is the rook
to f4 so here Joanne Jun goes back with
the Queen Queen to c6 it adds a third
attacker to the c-4 square but now just
Queen captures on e3 and now you have a
problem you cannot start grabbing
material with characters and captures
because of Queen f4 now going after
Queen
to have seven and the bishop here
prevents anyone from coming to help out
along the seventh ranked because well
the division guards the c7 square so
here after King age seven you you'd see
Queen f7 rook f6 is coming there's
nothing to do you cannot move the bishop
because of mate you cannot bring any
pieces to help out with the defense so
you could try something like rugby 8 but
rook f6 and now if Queens see it or
something it's it's hard to even make a
move g4 this is crucial because it will
allow Queen to hh5 after the rook is
sacrificed and h6 and here there are
just no moves whatever you play let's
say rugby 7
look at verse on h6 you cannot go here
you cannot go here you have to capture
and now Queen to h5 will be made so if
you start going after material you're
basically getting made it so here Queen
back the e8 joined room brings the Queen
back to help out with the defense Queen
to eat you now just keeping keeping the
material so not allowing black to grab
that pawn back Queen to g6 and now comes
Luke to f3 with ideas of rook to g3
which will put a lot of pressure on the
g7 pawn king to h7 and now comes Queen
to F - this is a beautiful move Queen f2
because here
okay you're up upon but how do you ever
unpin here unless you do this
so rook to f3 followed by Queen to f2 is
an excellent maneuver of how to unpin
because now you're threatening rook
captures and I fade so here Bester back
to c6 attacking the rook and now rook g3
attacking the Queen Queen f5 offering a
queen trade now Queen e2 again what do
you do here we have worked the d8 and
here comes Knight to e3
pushing back the Queen we have Quinta f7
and now again this is the the most
critical position ever so feel free to
pause the video and try to find the
hidden supercomputer move while I give
you a couple of seconds
so for those of you who are able to do
it congratulations on finding such a
supercomputer move I know it's always
easier when I tell you there's a hidden
supercomputer move but either way
congratulations and for those of you who
just want to enjoy the show it's
actually d5 d5 is is a hard move to find
because there is just too much to take
into account we're just gonna play it
Queen to b3 check it it's a similar idea
although it's much better if you combine
it with the d5 for the following reason
now with the d5 there there is not a lot
of things you can do if root characters
then Knight captures rook if Bishop
captures then you play queen d3 check
after the King moves or g6 doesn't
really matter c4 wins the bishop you
cannot move the bishop because the rook
hangs on the 8th so after d5 you're only
good option is pawn captures on d5 and
this is crucial because here you've
evaded the f5 square for the White
Knight but even more important the
bishop no longer has access to the f3
square which will help you bring a rook
into the attack so here after it
captures on d5 there are some some ideas
you could try but well why whatever you
do Queen d3 trip is is important and now
if King goes back like taking to h8 or
let's say King to g8 it doesn't really
matter
here you have Knight to g4 and now
you're threatening Knight captures here
with Czech Knight captures here sorry
Knight f6 check there's there are so
many so many ideas here if you allow
Knight f6 check the King moves to h8 and
then just Queen to h7 is made so not not
much you can do here and the other line
for example after Queen to d3 check
which is g6 now this comes into play
again Knight to g4 just you know with
the Knight to f6 check coming Bishop to
g7 and now rook to f3 this is the the
point why D if I was so strong because
now the bishop cannot capture rook and
now after Queen to e7 now you just play
characters captures and now Queen to f1
threatening rook f7 to win the Queen and
after rugby sell
doesn't really matter which is the only
move just checking a trade you pick up
the rook Bishop captures and now rook f8
check King h7 and here rook F seven wins
the Queen it's game over so that's why
after Queen to have seven d5 it's a it's
a monstrosity of a move but of course
who would find that so Queen to d3 check
it's similar idea the problem is it
doesn't go all the way because the
bishop covers f3 square so here of
course Jew engine does not move the King
g6 is played and now you can't go into
the same land because you don't have
access to f3 so look the g4 was played
now what actually wants to make the root
lift via rook to f4 so Bishop to g7
Bishop captures with key sorry not Queen
captures King captures was played and
now Knight to c4 now the night is coming
to e5 and well then there will be just
so much pressure on the g6 pawn so
Bishop to b5 first not allowing this and
now Queen to g3 unpinning
we have Bishop captures on c4 you cannot
allow this Knights to reach a 5
otherwise it's over B captures on c4 and
now rook to d7 I'm just adding another
defender to the seventh rank and then
now rook to e4 so here now we're in an
basically in an endgame with with garage
gonna being up upon so Queen f6 in the
now Queen to e3 putting pressure under
on the pawn here now of course you
cannot go to e7 because of d5 so Brooke
the d6 and now c5 pushing the road back
rook the c6 you have to keep an eye on
the pawn here now King g1 before
deciding on what to do first improving
the position of the King we have Queen
at five and now rook F for pushing the
Queen back Queen g5 now h4 Queen has to
go back now Queen e5 check King to g8
and now rook f6 putting pressure on g6
King h7 defending but now h5 a very
important attacking move which clears
the path for the rook to the h6 pawn G
captures now Queen f4
going after this and also just looked
ff7 wins the Queen so II five Baiju in
June there really aren't any any good
moves here so Queen captures was played
King to g8 and now Queen g6 check we
have king to h8 or if you block when g7
doesn't really matter just Queen e8
check and then now well you just lose
King here let's say rook F seven wins
the Queen
so after Queen g6 check King h8 and now
we have Queen captures on h5 with check
King g8 and now Queen to g5 check and it
was in this position that Jew and June
resigned the game and a most important
victory for Alexandra goralina who again
equalizes and they are now going into
rapid tiebreaks which will be which will
be played tomorrow so really impressive
stuff here you resign because you're
just down too much material doesn't
really matter whatever you do you can
just trade Queens captures captures you
trade rooks and then play d5 it's a it's
a clean win captures and now this just
gets gets the point of the board there's
there's no no playing this whatsoever
so after Queen g5 Jew in June resigns
and the water what a game in the water
went by Corey actually not like as part
of against Karpov in civilian 1987 an
offbeat opening then at some point we
actually know like as part of started
playing for an attack and then in the in
the end it was just pointless so like
like Karpov Julian June resigned and it
was it was just beautiful so now that's
the game I do hope you enjoyed it we are
gonna cover the tiebreaks as well
hopefully there will be some crazy games
there is of course there's there's less
time to think about the moves I would
like to thank John Bittinger a team of
Solo and Endre Yogi for a contribution
to my channel thank you a lot - really
appreciate it as usual you can check to
my previous video serum thankful for
watching and I will see you soon
continuing the coverage of the Women's
World Chess Championship the coverage of
the Tata Steel perhaps we're gonna check
up on some games from the Gibraltar
chess festival and of course continuing
the morphe saga and checking up on your
wonderful suggestions so thank you all I
will see you soon and have an excellent
rest of your day